foreign
[Music]
and today I'm going to talk about
artificial intelligence unveiling new
opportunities in cancer research
artificial intelligence is taking over
different fields in science we already
see it everywhere including clinical
research and precision medicine driving
exponential advances make Healthcare
so the global Healthcare Focus
artificial intelligence Market continues
to grow exponentially rich in and
estimated by a lieu of 5 billion in 2020
over the last 10 years and it is
expected to continue to rise to an
estimated of 44.5 billion by 2026.
I'm a surprise that huge Investments are
being made to support AI solutions for
clinical research AI has helped the
discovery of new therapies for the
treatment and timely detection of
difficult to treat diseases such as
cancer
so well in this talk we will focus on
what is artificial intelligence or AI
why it is so important and how AI can be
applied to cancer research
also
at the end of this talk we will be able
to get an overview of the application of
AI in clinical and cancer research we
will meet the challenges of implementing
AI in clinical and cancer research labs
and we will see how alarms increase the
possibility of applying AI to clinical
and cancer research with its
well first let's figure it out what is
AI
well artificial intelligence or AI can
be defined in several ways it is a
computer program designed to perform
operations typical of human intelligence
such as self-learning it is also
referred to algorithms which use data to
make decisions or predictions
well to build an algorithm scientists
create a set of instructions or codes
for the computer to follow and analyze
the data and make data driving decisions
so well in this area of Technology
developers across the globe are talking
about embracing artificial intelligence
or AI machine learning or ML and deep
learning or DL well these acronyms are
often used in the field of technology
and it is important to understand that
all these requirements are part of the
umbrella of AI
well let's see the difference well as we
saw earlier AI is a computer that
perform tests commonly associated with
human intelligence
algorithm algorithms I'm sorry or models
are codes that tell the computer how to
act and how to make decisions and learn
well the machine learning is a type of
AI it is not programmed to perform a
specific tasks but it can learn to make
predictions or decisions the more data
the ml model is exposed to the better it
will perform
and as for deep learning this is a
subset of ml that uses
um artificial neural networks modeled
after how the human brain process
information to learn from large amounts
of data
so now that we see the difference
between everything of this artificial
intelligence
the next question will be why is
artificial intelligence so important
well
technology is a key factor that drives
the latest advances in modern medicine
the combination of a Al a I am with ML
and other tools using Precision medicine
is indispensable in the fast-paced
environment of cancer research the
application of AI and cancer well can be
for example
to
um re recruiting and selecting subjects
or participants and in a study also AI
speeds up the research in drug Discovery
and increases Precision at every step of
critical trials and we know that having
drugs faster and that are not rejected
in phase four of clinical trial final
stages is crucial for cancer research
so now now let's see how AI helps
clinical research Labs well we know that
there are challenges that the clinical
researchers face every single day
obtaining reliable results is not that
easy and those are crucial for a better
understanding of new diseases and the
development of new drugs
will also follow strict protocols and
the standards they have to follow this
to protect the safety and privacy of
participants to end well to ensure high
quality data for affected Data Drive and
decision making
so AI bridged the gap between raising
Against Time and eliminating human
errors and also to meeting standard
operation procedures like Sops and
regulations
so
let's see also AI in drug Discovery
because another minor challenge that the
researchers face every time it's the
recurring cancers this can evolve and
acquire the worst-timer drug resistance
therefore there is a need to
continuously discover new drugs to face
this cancer drug resistance
so however well carrying out a drug
development is tedious is lab ruse is
expensive taking around like 15 years in
cost in pharmaceutical companies several
millions of dollars
AI is used to detect and interpret the
characteristic of Target molecules for
example proteins that are important in
cancer growth make predictions of new
drugs to Target those molecules and help
assess the efficacy of new drugs
so the rich the research is also be done
to identify novel approaches to create
new drugs more effectively
so in drug discovery
there are eight tools that have been
used by researchers for several years
all these two speed up their long
process of discovering a drug and put it
within the reach of the patient for
example there is the in silica Statics
these are experiments that Aid in the
identification of drug-like molecules
and targets by using bioinformatic tools
there is another one that is the key
sword this is the quantity structure
activity relationship this is a
mathematical relationship with
correlates molecular properties to some
specific biological activity
buddakistar the researchers attempt to
find consistent relationship between the
biological activity and molecular
properties based of course in the
functional groups that has these
molecules
another one is the document this is just
in drug Discovery for this the study of
protein ligand interactions the docking
has the ability to predict how small
molecules interact with the target
binding sites if of course they they are
also with these functional groups on the
protein and the molecule they see the
interactions with that
and another example is the Admiral mode
modeling these tools
will allow the medicinal chemist to
Target molecules with the greatest
shares of meeting the requirements of a
pharmacot kinetic criteria within in
every phase in the absorption
distribution metabolism expression and
toxicity
so
well once a drug is a sign the clinical
trials begin there are also lung
processes
the test of a surgeon drug begins well
they're positive and negative
implications that will be distorted
there is a potential for long-term side
effects
usually well the newly is synthesized or
drugs may look good in vitro but
um
may not always have the same benefits
for everyone due to differences in age
group lifestyle and prevalent health
conditions
so well the drugs cannot be put into
action immediately in a large part of
the population so that's why the test
phases are designed before the medicinal
use is approved so the AI helps sit
through the vast amounts of medical
records and generate data that can help
find eligible populations for a clinical
trial and also I have researchers to
randomize this double-blind studs
so let's see how
AI helps in a supporting participant
Recruitment and selection
so well in clinical trials the
Recruitment and Retention of
participants are two major lifet jumps
and are a major contributions to delays
researchers are often short time and
resources so AI can help cancer research
by recruiting and selecting subjects of
participants from
um in a story of course
so they can take advantage of of the AI
to select the participants for patient
medical records or pathology reports
based on specific criteria
these can be achieved by mining patient
information to identify potential
candidates with characteristics that are
needed for the research using
mathematical models so AI helps identify
which participants May respondents to
the drug treatment and also predict the
Dropout rates
this can increase the enrollment safe
resources and increases the accuracy and
validity of the research
so
in cancer well AI improves breast cancer
detection in cancer research AI can be
applied when specific symptoms are
entered into an AI system
it helps indices propulses and can
suggest possible treatment options so
some scientists of the NCI have
developed an artificial intelligence
technology to Aid in screening for
several types of cancer including breast
cancer
AI based software has been used to help
clinicians to interpret mammograms for
more than 20 years and research in this
area is evolving faster than ever
there is an a algorithm that can help
determine how often a person should have
a mammogram and the model can predict
risk of developing breast cancer for
five years
using images from a person's monogram
so
the FCI researchers train a computer
algorithm to analyze the MRI images of
the prostate
15 years ago Clinic chance began
performing biopsies guided for MRI
findings allowing them to focus
attention on regions of the prostate
most likely to develop cancer
so this MRI guided biopsy improve the
diagnosis and treatment when used by Pro
prostate cancer experts so the
researchers used AI to capture their
diagnostic experience and make an
algorithm accessible to all the clinics
across the country
and another group of the NCI also used
an AI to develop a system for the
automatic detection of cervical
precancerous lesions from digital images
this helps in the early detection of
cancer
there is another application for AI and
cancer and it's in genomic and
characterization of fumes AI technology
can also help in the identification of a
specific genetic mutations based on
images of tumor pathology instead of
using traditional genomic sequencing so
there are some researchers of the NCI
that use deep learning or the altitude
analyze pathology images of lung tumors
from the cancer genome Atlas so the TL
method accurately distinguish
between two of the most common lung
cancer subtypes the adenine carcinoma
and chromos pulse this chromosome
personality sorry and also predict
camera limited genes from the images
so the AI can help also in cancer
treatment
there are many studies that have
suggested that the AI has the potential
gather prognostic information from
images scans more accurately than humans
currently do like in the other examples
so the scientists have created a DL
model that can determine the likelihood
that a bladder cancer patient will need
treatments other than surgery
so the doctor estimated that about 50
percent of people with bladder muscle
tumors have clusters of cancer cells
that have to spread bridge on the
bladder but are too small to detect if
these cells are not removed they can
continue grow after surgery and can
cause a relaxed so this model analyzes
images of tumor tissue to predict
whether they are microscopic cancer
cells in nearby and lymph nodes so this
deep learning model was shown to be more
accurate that the standard weight of
predicting
whether bladderic cancer has a spread
which is based on a combination of
factors including the patient's age and
certain characteristics of the tumor so
the chemotherapy can remove this
microscopic plants and prevent the
cancer from coming back after surgery
so well
after seeing this all these applications
you will surely be wondering how it is
possible to implement Implement them in
my lab
so implementing AI clinical research can
be slow and libraries and Regulatory for
those can interfere with the integration
eight tools
privacy issues and ethical dilemas could
this accelerated this AI based
advancements in cancer research so to
bridge this Gap a laboratory information
management system or a limbs plays a
critical role
a cloud-based lens minimize challenges
by anonymizing sensitive patient data
the storing informed consents of sort of
the subjects or participants also helps
to enroll in participants and Associates
with the study the stores clinical
information and generates reports of the
different criteria
also making implementation of AI in
clinical research easy so lenskin helps
you a lot
let's see how
well a limbs anonymize sensitive
participant data and assigned role-based
protect health information access right
to the staff so the mask data can be
viewed only by authorized personal each
time an authorized person views or makes
change on to this protect health
information well the activity is
recorded in the audit Trail so this is
really useful because sometimes in the
audits external Auditors can request a
Phi audit report at any time so the
limbs have it for you automatically
also limbs manage to inform consent of
participants and track records of
participants who had with round their
consent
so also a lens
can manage participant Recruitment and
Associate simple data effectively
new participant records with their
personal and Healthcare information can
be recorded in your lips different
samples are collected from participants
can be registered and associated with
the corresponding patient records also a
limbs can be integrated with that a i
based tool to screen and pull out
subject records that match specific
criteria for a specific study or
research making the participant
recruitment process really easy
so when the patients are enrolling well
and alarms can helps to create a cancer
research story and associate with the
subjects with the participants a good
list allows you to create a cancer
research study and Associate their
participants with it so in this way all
the participants are associated with a
specific story you are not going to mix
them
Our Lives also helps in managing the
clinical history of participants by
integrating a lens with AI based data
analysis tools well the researchers can
further process the data and do
Downstream analysis so you have
everything in your links all the medical
history of your participants are in just
one um place
and also our limbs helps you to generate
custom reports on different criteria
this enables the researchers to make
data driving decisions so you can
customize as you wish and as you want
with your logo or with with your study
of with your research study as you wish
with just signatures and everything you
need
so well in conclusion let's summarize
the information that we got here so what
is artificial intelligence what is a
simulation of human intelligence
processes by computers why is artificial
intelligence so important well this
improved efficiency and eliminate human
errors and in increased reliability
so how can AI can be applied to cancer
research well use informatics it's
really easy to do it with this
so thank you very much for your
attention today